Well, there I was, that day
there was a basketball game and
I wanted to lose a number. I was seeing it there in
the
[Music]
no
hello people, sweetheart and here to
talk about my
style history a daily  star style
store and the beginnings I always like to
dress to be independent in that area
as you always see when I was little Malaga,
that is to say, it is always colored
because I wanted to wear it but it was not
like I was
and positions and trying is the rapper
but he tries so hard  It seems bad
that going to that date that I was
12 13 to 12 years old or it was like for seventh
eighth grade
I was already growing up there that when
I wanted a new piece of clothing what
made the piece pop and stole the
best shirt I could have but it is
now my daughter is now my daughter
but from the beanie of the voice of
jazz you need a yankee cap at
that moment because I wanted you to know I don't know how to
imitate some reggaeton player who puts
on rice is something  what do I know  more confident little
boy 12 years old the beanie for the
pop side like for sure daddy yankee or something
like that I went with her
you had a hero of the style someone
I admired and I couldn't get
that he had a black like that wow
I want to dress like that guy
but that  It is for
2007-2008 now at that time at
least where I am from the way I
grew up it was not like I had to be
on TV and internet 24 hours 2 those who
could see it there at
noon that  It was here but
that's nice I hadn't gone out I think
at that time I didn't even know that I
hadn't gone out I found out today 23 years old
he would have bastards swallow
the glasses they look a little cheap for him
for the suit very comfortable tighten more
but  at least they combine being pretty
all of that has been fixed and borrowed
so now I was borrowed but I
liked that suit the fito fit me
well
I think that before that what
she wore was the blue suit that I
could never measure myself  that he arrived  It took another
hour in all the awards and I looked like a
bastard. Hell, it seemed out to us. When
you pick up a piece of clothing, the store looks at it like this
and then it hit blah lily and it looks
good, it was like that, there came bad pain, well,
I was there for me that day
there was a basketball game and the number
wanted to lose it's me I was watching it
there in the
[Music]
I think Havana the code is those
glasses I don't know where they came from led to say
it's a samsung
vida doctor mike that's what they say in  Spain if
the only thing in English like tomic in
Spain is silly
always makes you look elegant no
matter what you wear you already feel
elegant but
it was cold that day
what are you wearing on your finger it's gold it
looks like it's gold and  It was real with a
few flakes of
gold for the nails and I put it on
more than on the kid right now
I won't put it on again but I don't
regret it I put it on because I'm
super searched in Miami and that was the last
time  that I climbed a stage before
the pandemic that's what I thought that heavy jacket
10,000 pounds 10,000 swaroski that look
the jacket the jacket specifically
the laser work
I think a couple is a couple from
Berlin who are old in a house like this
where they took the
aml mania glory wow fame of the scale
and they brought
their jacket they will win 10,000 new figure
of
13,000 13,000 swarovski if I had a little
pressure on how I was going to look today, it is with
what I had another idea in mind of
what I wanted but it is even a [ __ ]
when I arrive  I felt pleased and asia
of bastard I
really like these I even like having the ones that make you sick even more
but I am one of those who kind
of fall in love with a tuna and I stay with it for a
while I'm giving it a pear
how the jacques brel campaign came
about  I don't know how I dream I passed by there
and saw that news was for sale doing
a bit of study and his name is maside
I really communicated I
've been a long time I like many America and
we made friends  With the proposal I really
liked the concept of everything from the line d
of the dance of that campaign, he even said
it's like, with everything I'm
doing now and with the disco country and
all the laps, I don't put January on my
clothes, but yes.  It's a music video, he makes me
a music video and I go with my mind
depending on a video as I have the
concept I almost always obviously
have my style and what it brings more or less I
tell him I want this I mean
translations and I  I'm setting up and
we work as a team like it's like
it comes and it brings me a boom like this I say
investigate the subject put the study I say
okay if not it's like everything
obviously for that well no because only
a campaign of a line that is that  I was going
to come out like I was going to be able to but drop
that whole look for some reason it's one of
my favorites top five all time from
everyone's shoes from the glasses to
my hair from my face everything I was perfect that day
beautiful beautiful sexy but that day
specifically  I  I felt I felt
good bastard as we see spoli that
we call overwhelming
is a [ __ ] a mouth they only sell it
openly but it is specifically
but that it was an expensive search for a bastard
like the few of a peso and that most
surely they do not expect 300 pesos
this  aspires unanimously but that is where he
with the reason why I used that
outfit why
and it goes with the concept a bit of the video
of the song on that occasion I was
interpreting the 200 babies that is with
julieta venegas and time and the video
It starts like that with tiny struggling
like a laboratory and a ham like a
robot girl and that's how it gave me
futuristic and the video
julieta venegas no no she couldn't be
present at the awards this is just
like that in a virtual way there was
like that  a robot a robot playing and
then like her face on a
screen playing the piano and above all
part of the concept of the presentation
but it seems that it was planned
with time and it was not for him  moment
like when wishes are requested or as a reservation
for the presentation because it's like
nothing else
with everything there was something that inspired me at
some point it was a series a series I
was watching a little doll and put it on
where there was a character that was uncovered
like the hat and  that I had on my
forehead, that is, it's not like I hadn't
seen it before, but specifically when
I saw that because I have 10
clubs for those prizes, even when
they brought me that optic it was like
a jacket and I said I like the shirt so much
that it pricked  jacket I mean
something like this two legs
you received a lot of praise for this
video how was the process in making
it that was one day I had 24 hours
recording that video 24 hours non-stop I
mean non-stop not obviously they took their
break but because with everyone  the changes,
looks, hairstyles, makeup,
that took
time when I put on the one with the breasts,
so most of my videos are more or less created
,
but this one specifically is  It's my favorite
because the concept that I delivered I
gave the
trident to the director complete
details
and he complied with each of the
details and everything was just as I
thought
this is also my top five of my
favorite looks the time with that one is  It was
more or less around the same time
when the newspaper looked cute I
loved that
suit and what brand was the derby?
Gabriela gave me that flower and I decided to
use it like
when I went out the last thing I
was  dress and when I went to leave
the house I am missing there is a detail and a
favorite welcome flower
also come back and come back and it is not
like now
I would not say rabbit because they are not like
short but they are like d
of a little animal and I don't think the glasses
Let them be back and I don't remember the brand but
I like all that light I like how I
looked all that day it's beautiful beautiful
beautiful the award that day was not the
grammy it was me grammy will be a bat bonnie it
's like seeing a sitting dream and already like
that  It's not like in my biography the
only one hints at painting her nails at 12
years of age
July 13, 1992
it was also Gabriela like we played
playing but like the United States
that day I felt unhappy they are lies
dreams of yellow
memories people can  to say the one with the nails and it's
a really [ __ ] scandal like
gold women like me when I was
painting my nails at that moment I
wasn't thinking about the world and
what the Latino men
specifically were more like the boy  I
wasn't thinking about that, nor was I
thinking that after that,
more people, man, are going to say
hell,
well, and they
also talk about it. I've always
liked it, I don't dare let it reach
everyone who already did it, he
's shy  It's like they didn't point it out anymore, I
wasn't thinking about it, I don't even think
about it, like I don't know,
but when in that photo they took there
, I already needed a challenge.
s grammy and well,
that one, well,
a grammy I think the
pants and obviously the knee pads
are wichis but I don't remember if the shirt
was also it was it was it was gucci so it was a
good day and I was very nervous I like
bobcats a lot I have always liked them  I liked
what happens that since I have a
very big head it is always very difficult to
find the mouth is that they whistle at me because
for some reason the bastards in the
stores every sun there are
small
or maybe online
but it doesn't work for me
no I don't want to do anything else  but let me
see what you have and fast the rest
damn
after
that
are watching
thank you so much people for sharing
with me and listening to my
story history
because now
[Music]